PREVIOUSLY ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,"
CASSANDRA HAD TROUBLE SHEDDING
HER BEAUTY PAGEANT IMAGE...
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO SAY
BYE-BYE TO BEAUTY QUEEN.
I LOVE MY HAIR.
NO MORE BEAUTY PAGEANTS.
WHILE SARAH FOUND RELIEF
FROM COMPETITION
IN HER FRIENDSHIP WITH KIM...
I'LL MAKE OUT WITH YOU, KIM.
OH, LIKE, WHATEVER.
AND WHEN EBONY FAILED
TO CONVEY HER HIGH ENERGY
IN HER PHOTO...
I'M JUST GETTING DEAD CARCASS
ON A FENCE RIGHT NOW.
DIANE.
SHE WAS SENT HOME.
11 GIRLS REMAIN.
WHO WILL BE ELIMINATED TONIGHT?
♪♪♪
IT WAS DEFINITELY
AN EMOTIONAL PANEL.
IT WAS.
WE SEE THIS BEAUTIFUL BODY,
BUT WE HAVEN'T SEEN
THIS BEAUTIFUL BODY
CAPTURED IN A PHOTO.
DIANE.
YOU DON'T KNOW THE FEELING
TILL YOU'RE THERE.
MM-HMM.
THAT JUST MAKES ME WORK
EVEN HARDER.
HELLO.
(all)
HI.
TYRA!
HOW ARE YOU GUYS?
WE'RE GOOD.
I KNOW IT WAS A HARD JUDGING,
RIGHT?
(all)
YEAH.
YEAH, IT WAS REALLY DIFFICULT
FOR THE JUDGES, TOO.
AND I THINK IT'S BECAUSE
YOU GUYS ARE ALL SO STRONG
AND SO UNIQUE.
YOU ALL HAVE THAT MODEL THING,
SO IT'S REALLY, REALLY HARD.
TYRA STOPPING BY TO SEE HOW
WE ARE DOING IS JUST
REALLY HELPFUL TO ALL OF US
AND IT ALSO PROVIDED
A SENSE OF COMFORT.
HOW MANY OF YOU GUYS
WATCH "TOP MODEL" AND THINK,
"DANG, THAT'S SO EASY.
I COULD DONE THAT PICTURE
SO MUCH BETTER THAN HER"?
COME ON. COME ON.
MY BIGGEST PROBLEM IS
I DON'T KNOW HOW MY BODY LOOKS
ALL THE TIME.
YOU CAN'T STEP OUTSIDE YOUR BODY
AND SEE, OKAY, I NEED TO MOVE
THIS WAY, THIS WAY, THIS WAY.
BUT WHEN YOU PERFECT IT,
YOU CAN STEP OUT OF YOUR BODY
AND SEE IT.
'CAUSE ONE DAY IT IS GONNA
BECOME NATURAL, AND ONE DAY
MODELING IS GONNA BE
SECOND NATURE FOR YOU GUYS.
OKAY?
- TYRA MAIL.
TYRA MAIL!
"GET READY TO SWIM WITH
THE SHARKS.
BE READY AT 12 P.M."
(cheering)
IT WAS JUST KIND OF
A STRESSFUL DAY.
- WE'RE JUST EXHAUSTED.
- OH, IT'S KINDA COLD OUT HERE.
AND WE ALL JUST KINDA
GO AND CRASH AND TRY TO REGROUP.
YEAH.
SARAH AND I MADE OUT ONCE
IN THE LIMO AND, YOU KNOW,
WE WERE A LITTLE TIPSY.
(screaming)
I'VE DEALT WITH
STRAIGHT GIRLS FOR A LONG TIME,
YEARS AND YEARS AND YEARS,
AND I, LIKE, KNOW THEM
LIKE THE BACK OF MY HAND.
LIKE THE LAST PEOPLE I'VE DATED
HAVE ALL HAD,
LIKE, ATTACHMENT ISSUES.
AND IT'S HARD 'CAUSE, LIKE,
I DON'T HAVE ANY.
AND SO, LIKE, I ALLOW
MYSELF TO BE VULNERABLE,
AND THEN THEY DO TOO,
AND THEN THEY FLIP OUT,
AND I'M JUST LIKE, OKAY.
I DIDN'T MEAN TO GRAVITATE
TOWARDS KIM AT ALL,
BUT THERE IS SO MUCH TENSION IN
THE HOUSE, IT'S EASY TO FOCUS
ON SOMEONE TO GET YOUR MIND OFF
OF EVERYTHING ELSE.
I ALWAYS FEEL REALLY
TIED DOWN BY PEOPLE.
SO, LIKE, WHEN YOU GET CLOSE
TO SOMEONE, YOU FREAK OUT.
YEAH. I JUST DON'T THINK I HAVE
MET THE RIGHT PERSON.
BUT IF I SAY, "NO, TYRA,"
SHE'S GONNA BE LIKE,
"PACK YOUR BAGS."
TYRA SAID LAST NIGHT
AT THE ELIMINATION
THAT SHE WANTED TO CUT
MY HAIR EVEN MORE.
I'M GONNA HAVE YOU
GET THE HAIRCUT
THAT I WANTED YOU
TO HAVE.
I SPECIFICALLY SAID MIA FARROW
IN "ROSEMARY'S BABY,"
AND THAT HAIR IS VERY,
VERY SHORT.
AND YOU'RE ONE OF THOSE
RARE WOMEN THAT I THINK
CAN HANDLE IT.
I JUST WAS SO ANGRY
AT THAT POINT.
WHEN I GET UP IN THE MORNING
AND I LOOK IN THE MIRROR
AND I DON'T HAVE ANY HAIR,
I'M STILL JUST, LIKE,
MAN, THIS SUCKS.
I HAVE A 1 IN 11 SHOT NOW.
YOU CAN'T THINK
ABOUT YOUR CHANCES,
YOU HAVE TO THINK ABOUT, LIKE,
IS THIS WHAT YOU REALLY
WANT TO DO?
YEAH.
AND IF THIS IS WHAT YOU
REALLY, REALLY WANT TO DO,
THEN I SAY CUT IT.
WE PULL UP IN THIS
KIND OF RITZY NEIGHBORHOOD,
AND IT'S A SUNSHINE DAY,
IT'S PERFECT.
SO I'M KINDA THINKING
WELL, MAYBE WE'LL JUST GET
TO RELAX AND HAVE A POOL PARTY.
AND THEN I LOOK UP
AND THERE'S MISS J...
♪♪♪
IN SOME CRAZY GETUP, AS USUAL.
WHAT'S UP, GIRLS?
HEY.
I KNEW RIGHT THEN
I DON'T THINK I WAS GONNA HAVE
A RELAXING AFTERNOON.
TODAY WE'RE GONNA JUMP FROM
FLIPPERS TO HEELS.
YOU MAY BE DOING
A FASHION SHOW ON GRASS
ON STONES, EVEN GLASS.
BUT TODAY YOU WILL HAVE TO WALK
AROUND THE PERIMETERS
OF THE SWIMMING POOL.
THE FIERCEST RUNWAY WALK
POSSIBLE.
HOPEFULLY THROUGH THIS LESSON
TODAY, THESE GIRLS LEARN
SOMETHING ABOUT THEIR WALKS.
BECAUSE THEY NEED
THEIR PRESENCE TO CARRY THEM
THROUGHOUT A FASHION SEASON.
♪♪♪
BRE--FOR THE ORIGINAL WALK,
I THOUGHT SHE WAS GREAT.
OKAY, SHE'S WORKING IT OUT.
KYLE JUST NEEDS TO BE
COMFORTABLE WITH BEING TALL.
GIVE IT A LICK, BABY.
NIK NEEDS TO PICK UP HER PACE
A BIT MORE.
A LITTLE MORE ENERGY,
A LITTLE MORE SPEED.
HIT IT.
JAYLA, YOU ARE SO
OUT OF TOUCH.
JAYLA TENDS TO WALK
A BIT SCATTERED.
THEY DO SAY SEX SELLS.
I THOUGHT DIANE SEEMED
THE MOST WILLING TO LEARN.
BEAUTY PAGEANT, BEAUTY PAGEANT,
BEAUTY PAGEANT GIRL.
EVERY TIME I TURN AROUND,
THEY'RE LIKE,
"PAGEANT, PAGEANT,
PAGEANT, PAGEANT."
SHUT UP.
WE NEED FASHION MODEL.
YOU'RE ALMOST THERE.
COME ALIVE.
COME ALIVE IN THE FACE,
COME ALIVE IN THE FACE.
SHAKE IT BUT DON'T BREAK IT,
BECAUSE THE BOYS WON'T TAKE IT.
OW! I LOVE IT.
NICOLE'S POSES ARE JUST
A BIT COLLAPSIBLE.
HOW MANY PACKS OF GUM
ARE YOU CHEWING WHEN YOU WALK?
- LOTS OF THEM.
- OKAY.
LISA IS NOT FOCUSED.
SHE HAS TO FIND HER CENTER.
TIPPY TUMBLES, BETTER KNOWN
AS MISS SARAH.
I HOPE I GET TO, LIKE,
PROVE MYSELF TO J.
THAT I DON'T REALLY SUCK
ON THE RUNWAY AS MUCH
AS EVERYONE THINKS I DO.
SARAH, I NEED MORE NECK.
- MORE NECK, BABY.
- WHAT DO YOU MEAN?
I DON'T HAVE MORE NECK.
WHENEVER SOMEONE
SPEAKS TO YOU,
YOU LOSE CONCENTRATION.
AND THEN YOU DO THE TURTLE.
THIS SHOULD BE REAL SPECIAL
BECAUSE YOU ARE SPECIAL.
I WANT TO TRY TO PUT
MY OWN PERSONALITY INTO IT,
BUT ALSO HAVING
A FEMININE FLAIR,
AND IT'S JUST DIFFICULT FOR ME.
OHH.
IT'S A BIT MARIONETTE
WITHOUT THE STRINGS.
KIM HAS AN INCREDIBLE FACE.
SHE SHOULD BE ABLE TO DO
REALLY, REALLY WELL,
BUT UNFORTUNATELY,
WE DON'T HAVE FIVE YEARS.
BEHIND YOU HERE,
I HAVE A BASKET.
I WANT YOU EACH
TO PULL OUT HAT.
WITH THAT, YOU NEED
TO HAVE ON ONE OF THESE.
IT IS A SKIRT.
PERSONALITY IS SO VERY, VERY KEY
IN RUNWAY WALKING BECAUSE YOU
HAVE TO MODEL FOR SO MANY
DIFFERENT DESIGNERS WITH
SO MANY DIFFERENT CONCEPTS.
GIRLS, NOW THAT YOU HAVE CHOSEN
YOUR HAT, I WANT YOU EACH
TO DANCE AROUND THE ROOM.
WE NEED THE GIRLS
TO ACTUALLY BE
A LITTLE MORE OVER THE TOP.
I THOUGHT THEY COULD
LOOSEN UP BY DANCING.
♪♪♪
USE THE HAT AS AN ACCESSORY.
PLAY WITH IT, WORK IT.
I NEED TO SOMEHOW BRING
MY MASCULINITY AND FEMININITY
INTO THE WALK.
I'M LOST FOR WORDS.
USUALLY, I HAVE
SOMETHING TO SAY.
I AM REALLY LOST FOR WORDS.
IF ANYONE SHOULD UNDERSTAND
A DIFFERENCE OF
GENDER EXPRESSION,
SHE SHOULD BE THE ONE.
I MEAN, ARE YOU KIDDING?
I DID SAY INTERPRETIVE.
I DIDN'T SAY CRAZY.
LISA IS JUST REALLY
ALL OVER THE PLACE.
CHILD, THAT LITTLE DANCE
IS MAKING ME CLUTCH MY PEARLS.
CASSANDRA LOOKED
EXACTLY THE SAME.
NOTHING REALLY CHANGED.
WHOO!
SARAH IS JUST ONE BIG,
HUGE BALL OF CONFUSION.
(squealing)
AFTER I DID IT,
I KIND OF REALIZED
HOW DUMB I WAS.
SO I HOPE I NEVER HAVE TO
SEE THAT AGAIN.
OKAY, GIRLS.
WE KNOW WHO
THE WORST GIRLS WERE.
KIM AND MISS SARAH, KNOW THAT
YOU HAVE TO WORK EXTRA HARD.
SO REMEMBER, THE WALK LESSON
DOES NOT STOP HERE.
OKAY, BYE.
(all)
BYE.
TYRA MAIL.
"YOU DISCOVERED WHO'S FIERCE
AND WHO FALLS FLAT
"ON THE CATWALK.
"TOMORROW THE TABLES TURN.
BE READY AT 9:15 A.M."
I'M USED TO CROSSING
BECAUSE, WHEN WE DO PAGEANTS,
I CROSS.
BRE, CAN YOU HELP ME?
I ACTUALLY DIDN'T USED TO BE
SUCH A BAD WALKER.
I THINK I'M JUST
THINKING ABOUT IT WAY TOO MUCH,
AND IT'S IN MY HEAD
MORE THAN MY FEET.
I JUST NEED TO GET IT RIGHT
IN MY HEAD RIGHT NOW.
THEY KICKED SOMEONE OFF
BECAUSE OF THEIR BAD WALKING?
YEAH.
I'M USED TO BEING ONE OF
THE BEST AT THINGS THAT I DO.
THIS IS REALLY HARD FOR ME
BECAUSE I'M CERTAINLY NOT
ONE OF THE BEST.
ALL RIGHT, WHATEVER.
I'VE HAD ENOUGH.
MODELING ISN'T SOMETHING
KIM KNOWS WELL.
SO YOU STICK TO WHAT YOU KNOW.
YOU KNOW GIRLS,
YOU KNOW YOU LIKE 'EM,
AND YOU KNOW YOU'RE GOOD
AT GETTING THEM.
MY ARMS ARE SO STRONG.
YEAH, THEY LOOKED BIG
THE OTHER DAY.
WHAT DO YOU MEAN?
BUT KIM MIGHT WANT
TO PRACTICE THAT WALK OF HERS.
YOU CAN'T STUDY
THE DAY OF THE TEST.
IT JUST DOESN'T WORK LIKE THAT.
OH, I COULD NEVER DO THAT.
YESTERDAY WE GOT TYRA MAIL
SAYING THAT THE TABLES
WOULD BE TURNED AROUND TODAY,
OR WHATEVER.
HOPEFULLY IT'LL BE
SOMETHING EXCITING.
HEY, I JUST CLEANED.
YOU BETTER CLEAN AFTER YOURSELF.
I ALWAYS CLEAN EVERYTHING
I DO IN THIS KITCHEN,
ESPECIALLY WHEN I HAVE SEX HERE.
SARAH AND KIM
SEEM TO HANG OUT TOGETHER.
YOU CAN DEFINITELY TELL THAT
THEY'RE VERY CLOSE TO
EACH OTHER.
THIS IS SOME QUALITY MATERIAL
YOU SEE RIGHT IN FRONT OF YOU.
STRAIGHT GIRLS TEND TO GET
CRUSHES ON ME.
LIKE, I CAN'T PICK UP A GAY GIRL
TO SAVE MY LIFE.
POOR SARAH.
HEARTS ARE MADE
TO BE BROKEN, SISTER.
IT'S REALLY HARD, ACTUALLY,
TO TELL WHERE KIM IS AT
BECAUSE SHE IS SUCH A KIDDER.
ALL RIGHT, THE PRESENTATION'S
NOT GONNA BE GREAT.
WHY DO I EVEN TRY?
I GUESS I'M ATTRACTED TO HER
IN A WAY.
LOOK HOW GOOD IT IS.
COME HERE.
IT'S REALLY WEIRD TO ME
TO FEEL THAT WAY ABOUT A GIRL.
This isn't really
a principle.
This is vanity.
And it is beautiful hair,
but it does grow back.
My point is if it's
this short already,
an extra month or two isn't
gonna make that much difference.
YEAH, WELL, I DON'T KNOW.
I'M JUST REALLY PISSED OFF
ABOUT IT.
The question is do you love
your hair more than you love
this opportunity?
- HI, GIRLS.
- (all) HI.
I'M SUE WONG.
I'M A DESIGNER OF VERY DRAMATIC,
GLAMOROUS EVENING WEAR.
YESTERDAY YOU LEARNED
HOW TO WALK, AND TODAY
WE'RE GOING TO TEST
THAT ABILITY
WITH A RUNWAY PRESENTATION.
BEHIND ME IS THE RUNWAY, AND IN
FRONT OF THE RUNWAY WILL BE
THIS MOVING PLATFORM.
THIS IS INSANE.
YOU HAVE TO BE ABLE TO WALK,
BE THIS CHARACTER,
THEN ON TOP OF IT,
GO ON A TURNING THING AND HOLD
A POSE.
OKAY? IT'S NOT EASY.
TODAY, THE WINNER WILL HAVE
THE PRIVILEGE OF BORROWING
THIS REALLY GORGEOUS GOWN,
WHICH TYRA WORE
TO OPRAH'S LEGENDS BALL.
ARE WE READY FOR HAIR
AND MAKEUP?
(all)
YES.
OKAY, GREAT.
YEAH.
I CAN DEFINITELY WALK IN THESE.
THEY'RE FEELING GOOD.
I GUESS I'M JUST, LIKE,
A LITTLE BIT NERVOUS RIGHT NOW.
I FEEL LIKE AFTER YESTERDAY,
LIKE, THE LAST THING I NEEDED
WAS ANOTHER DAY OF RUNWAY.
SARAH, YOU'RE LUCKY
YOU HAVE SHORT HAIR.
LIKE PRINCESS LEIA.
I'M FEELING PRETTY NERVOUS,
BUT MY NEW PLAN IS TO WALK
VERY SLOWLY,
AS TO SO I DON'T FALL.
YOU'RE SHEHERAZADE,
AND YOU'RE IN A NORTHERN AFRICA.
CORYN IS REALLY NOT VERY
CONSCIOUS OF HER ENVIRONMENT.
YOU'RE AN EXOTIC
MONGOLIAN PRINCESS.
WHOOPS.
A LITTLE TIPSY.
SO I'M TRYING
TO KEEP MY BALANCE,
AND I COULDN'T STOP LAUGHING.
YOU'RE A BEAUTIFUL
INDIAN PRINCESS.
MY RUNWAY WALK IS SEXY
AND CONFIDENT AND PLAYFUL
ALL AT THE SAME TIME.
I HAVE A PRETTY GOOD IDEA
OF WHAT IS IN FRONT OF ME.
I KNOW THERE'S
THIS MOVING PLATFORM.
I'M ANTICIPATING KIND OF
A DISASTER.
A LITTLE ROUGH LANDING.
MORE ELEGANCE,
MORE GRACEFULNESS.
I WISH THAT THE CLOTHES
WEREN'T AS FEMININE AS THEY ARE.
BUT I DO WANT TO MODEL.
I DO WANT TO KEEP TRYING
TO DO THIS.
GIVE ME
A LITTLE BIT MORE MOVEMENT WITH
THE PANELS OF YOUR SKIRT.
KIM LACKS CONFIDENCE.
THAT WILL REALLY HURT HER
ON THE RUNWAY.
A LITTLE ROUGH ON THE ENTRY.
YOU'RE GOING TOO EGYPTIAN ON ME.
I'M NOT SURE WHETHER I LIKE
THE LIMP WRIST.
JUST PRETEND
YOU'RE ON THE STEPS
OF CENTRAL ASIA SOMEPLACE.
SO I GO ON
AND I'M LOVING IT.
I'M FEELING THE ATMOSPHERE.
I'M DOROTHY DANDRIDGE,
AND NOBODY
CAN TELL ME DIFFERENTLY.
BOLD AND DRAMATIC
AND BEAUTIFUL.
VERY NICE.
BRE SHOWS A LOT OF PROMISE.
SHE CAN TAKE THAT ATTITUDE
VERY FAR.
BE PLAYFUL, FUN, GIVE ME
A NICE SMILE.
ALL OF THE OTHER GIRLS,
WERE LIKE,
"I LOVE BEING ON THE RUNWAY.
WE GET TO DO A RUNWAY SHOW."
AND I WAS JUST LIKE,
"YEAH, OKAY."
MORE ELEGANT FINGERS.
CASSANDRA IS REALLY TOO STIFF,
A LITTLE BIT TOO CONTRIVED.
I'M IN THIS HUGE
WEDDING GOWN KIND OF THING.
AND THEN THERE'S THIS
HUGE THING ON MY HEAD.
IT'S SO MUCH TO THINK ABOUT
AT ONCE
THAT IT'S GETTING TO ME.
DROP YOUR GOWN, STAY CENTER,
STAY CENTER.
KEEP YOUR TRAIN BEHIND YOU.
YOU'RE NOT STAYING CENTER.
STAY CENTER.
I THINK YOU'RE MORE PREOCCUPIED
WITH THE TRAIN RATHER THAN
GETTING INTO CHARACTER.
SARAH WAS RATHER AWKWARD.
SHE NEEDS TO REALLY WORK
ON HER GRACEFULNESS.
FREEZE AND OFF STAGE.
AT THE END OF THE CHALLENGE,
WE'RE ALL HAVING MIXED FEELINGS
ABOUT HOW WE DID--
YOU KNOW, I'M FEELING,
OH, MY GOD, I THINK
I DID SO BADLY,
AND OTHER PEOPLE ARE LIKE,
"OH, GOD, THAT WAS
SO EXHILARATING AND WONDERFUL."
I WANT TO CONGRATULATE
AND THANK YOU FOR SUCH
A WONDERFUL PERFORMANCE,
AND, CONSIDERING
HOW CHALLENGING IT WAS,
I THINK YOU REALLY DID WELL.
AND THE WINNER THAT I CHOSE...
IS BRE.
(applause)
CONGRATULATIONS.
THANK YOU.
I'M THE WINNER.
I WON SOMETHING.
FINALLY!
IT WAS SO LONG OVERDUE.
YOU GET TO REALLY BORROW
THIS BEAUTIFUL FEATHER GOWN
FOR A VERY FANCY DINNER,
AND YOU GET TO CHOOSE
FOUR OF YOUR FAVORITE FRIENDS.
CORYN, KIM, NIK AND JAYLA.
WELL, CONGRATULATIONS,
LADIES.
YOU GET TO GO OUT IN THE NIGHT.
AS FOR THE REST OF YOU, SORRY.
I LOOK ABSOLUTELY BEAUTIFUL
IN THIS DRESS.
TYRA DID WEAR THIS DRESS.
I FEEL VERY SPECIAL RIGHT NOW.
WE'RE ALL LIKE,
"WHERE ARE WE GOIN'?"
HAVING A GREAT TIME
IN THE LIMO.
- LOOK AT THOSE FEATHERS.
- I KNOW.
WHEN WE GET TO THE RESTAURANT,
EVERYONE SITS DOWN AND WE
FIND OUT WE'RE HAVING CAVIAR
FOR DINNER.
SO EVERYONE IN THE GROUP
IS A LITTLE LIKE,
"OH, MY GOODNESS,
WE'RE HUNGRY.
WE DON'T WANT CAVIAR."
I WOULD SUGGEST
YOU TRY FIRST THE BROILED
BELUGA CAVIAR.
IT'S THE BEST ONE.
I WANT TO BE RESPECTFUL,
BUT I WANT TO THROW UP.
THIS DOESN'T TASTE SO WELL
AFTER ALL.
TYRA MAIL.
NO WAY.
"DON'T BE AFRAID,
BUT BE VERY AWARE.
"JUST BECAUSE IT'S NOT SEEN
DOESN'T MEAN IT'S NOT THERE.
BE READY AT 7 A.M., TYRA."
7 A.M.?
WHAT?
GOOD NIGHT.
I'M IN AN OPEN
RELATIONSHIP AT HOME.
SO, YOU KNOW, I WOULD BE ALLOWED
TO MAKE OUT OR WHATEVER.
I TOLD KIM SHE'S SPENDING
TOO MUCH TIME WITH THAT GIRL.
IF I WAS HER GIRLFRIEND,
I WOULD BE LIKE,
"ALL RIGHT, NOW EXPLAIN THAT."
HER GIRLFRIEND
WOULD KNOCK HER OUT.
I AM YOUNG AND I GUESS, UM,
CURIOUS.
I GUESS I'M A SEXUAL PERSON.
I JUST DON'T REALLY WANT
TO HAVE ANYTHING INTERFERE
WITH THE COMPETITION,
BUT, LIKE, SHE'S JUST
SUCH A BLONDE-HAIRED GIRL,
YOU KNOW?
AND LIKE, I LOVE BLONDES.
I REALLY DO.
I DON'T KNOW IF WE'RE
JUST FRIENDS OR IF WE ARE
STARTING SOMETHING.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON.
I'M NOT INTO STAYING UP
UNTIL ALL HOURS OF THE NIGHT,
HAVING LESBIAN LOVE AFFAIRS.
LET'S TRY TO BE
ON TOP OF OUR GAME
RATHER THAN BE TIRED
WHEN WE HAVE TO GO
TO A PHOTO SHOOT.
ALL IT WAS
WAS A STUPID MAKE OUT.
THAT'S ALL IT WAS.
IT WON'T BE ANY MORE THAN THAT.
STUPID MAKE OUT.
OKAY, THE FIRST ONE
WASN'T A MAKE OUT.
WE'RE JUST HAVING FUN.
YOU KNOW, GIRLS HAVE FUN
AND MAKE OUT WITH EACH OTHER.
IT'S LIKE WHAT GIRLS DO.
WHAT IS SHE GONNA DO, FLY
AND COME SEE YOU EVERY WEEKEND?
YOU BETTER STICK TO REALITY,
SWEETHEART.
SO WE'RE FLIRTY.
BUT THAT WAS ABOUT IT.
THE ONLY THING IS THOUGH
IS THAT SHE'S GAY.
SO IT'S, LIKE, WEIRD.
NO, NO, NO.
Good-bye.
NO, BRANDON, NO.
I DON'T SWING THAT WAY,
AND YOU KNOW IT.
You might.
I FEEL VERY CONFUSED
RIGHT NOW, I GUESS.
AND, LIKE,
I HAVE THE MEMORY OF ME,
BUT IT'S SO TANGLED RIGHT NOW.
I DON'T KNOW WHERE I AM
OR WHERE I STAND WITH ANYTHING.
HEY, GIRLS.
HEY.
SO TODAY WE'VE GOT
THIS HOLLYWOOD
SPECIAL EFFECT STYLE SHOOT
GOING ON.
WHAT YOU GUYS ARE ACTUALLY
GONNA BE DOING IS RUNNING
ON THIS MOVING RUNWAY.
BUT YOU'LL RUNNING AS IF
YOU ARE SCARED
OF SOMETHING BEHIND YOU.
BUT WE ARE NOT TELLING YOU
WHAT THAT OTHER ELEMENT IS.
AND THEN WE ARE GOING TO
POST EFFECT
EVERYTHING ELSE
IN AT THE END.
ALSO TODAY, WE HAVE
AN AMAZING PHOTOGRAPHER.
MIKE, COME ON IN HERE.
HOW ARE YOU DOING, GUYS?
GOOD MORNING.
TODAY YOU GIRLS ARE ALL
GONNA BE STYLED
AS FASHION VICTIMS.
YOU ALL ARE GONNA HAVE
SOMETHING A LITTLE WRONG
ABOUT YOU.
BUT YOU'RE ALL
GONNA LOOK RIGHT.
ALL RIGHT, SO I'M GONNA TAKE
YOU GUYS INTO HAIR AND MAKEUP
RIGHT NOW.
AND, JAYLA, CASSANDRA,
I WANT TO TALK TO YOU REAL QUICK
OVER HERE BY THE COUCH.
OKEYDOKE.
SO WE'RE ACTUALLY GONNA
TAKE OUT YOUR EXTENSIONS.
'CAUSE THEY FEEL LIKE
THEY'RE NOT WORKING WITH YOU.
SHE LOOKED MUCH BETTER WITH
THE SHORTER HAIR, PERSONALLY.
EVERYONE IS CALLING ME
ELVIRA.
WE'RE ACTUALLY GONNA TRIM
YOUR HAIR A LITTLE SHORTER.
WE'RE GONNA LEAVE IT LONG
AND THEN SCISSOR AND COMB UP
THE BACK A LITTLE BIT.
YOU MAY NOT LIKE IT AT FIRST,
BUT YOU HAVE TO GET INTO IT.
YOU HAVE TO TRY TO SEE
THE GOOD IN IT.
INITIALLY, WHAT TYRA
REALLY WANTED
WAS LIKE A MIA FARROW CUT.
- MM-HMM.
LIKE, SHE WANTS THIS ALL
A LOT SHORTER.
SEE, I'M NOT REALLY
COMFORTABLE CUTTING IT AGAIN
WHEN I HAVEN'T EVEN
GOTTEN A CHANCE
TO REALLY WORK IT YET.
SO WHAT'S GONNA HAPPEN,
YOU THINK?
IF YOU TURN TO A CLIENT
AND SAY, "YOU KNOW, I REALLY
DON'T WANT TO CUT MY HAIR,"
THEY'LL BE LIKE,
"YOU KNOW WHAT?
THANKS, CASSANDRA, BYE-BYE."
YEAH, I JUST--
I CAN'T DO A SHOOT WITHOUT
YOU HAVING YOUR HAIR
THE WAY THEY WANT IT, ALL RIGHT?
SO HAVE SOME BREAKFAST,
THINK ABOUT IT,
AND I'LL ASK YOU IN A FEW
MINUTES.
OKAY.
WELL, SHE CAN BE
TOWARDS THE END OF THE DAY.
ARE THEY COMING OUT, THOUGH?
THEY'RE JUST TAKING
A LONG TIME.
IF YOU WANT TO STAY, I STILL
HAVE RESPECT FOR YOU
FOR EVEN GOING UP
AND TALKING TO HIM.
I MEAN, I DO WANT TO STAY
AND I WANTED
TO TAKE THE PICTURES
AND REALLY GET A CHANCE
TO SHOW IT OFF NOW THAT
I FINALLY HAVE THE CONFIDENCE
TO BACK THIS UP, YOU KNOW?
GOD GIVES US
OUR FIRST INSTINCTS.
DON'T GO AGAINST IT.
I KNOW.
IN THIS SHOOT, IT'S
RATHER COMPLICATED.
WE HAVE TO ACT SCARED,
ACT BEAUTIFUL
AND RUN IN 5-INCH HEELS
AT THE SAME TIME.
SOMETHING'S COMING BACK
AT YOU, ABOUT TO GRAB YOU.
JUST SCARED AND PRETTY.
GOOD, JUST KEEP GOING.
THAT'S GREAT.
KEEP REACHING.
NIK KEPT CHANGING IT UP
WITH HER FACE AND HER BODY,
AND SHE WAS VERY BELIEVABLE
ON FILM.
IT'S COMING FOR YOU.
YOU'RE SCARED.
SOMETHING'S CHASING YOU.
SOMETHING'S COMING TO GET YOU.
LISA HAD AMAZING
BODY LANGUAGE.
BUT WHEN YOU CAN'T MARRY
THE BODY LANGUAGE WITH THE FACE,
YOU DON'T HAVE A PHOTO.
IT JUST KIND OF HAPPENED.
IT WAS SUCH A STRESSFUL NIGHT,
IT JUST SORT OF HAPPENED.
REALLY?
AND I WOKE UP FEELING LIKE
I WAS THE WORST GIRLFRIEND
IN THE ENTIRE WORLD.
I HAVE A GIRLFRIEND
WHO I CARE ABOUT
AND WHO I WANT
TO BE WITH WHEN I GET BACK.
I DON'T SEE ANYONE ELSE
IN THAT LIGHT, AND THAT'S IT.
DO YOU FEEL ANYTHING
FOR SARAH?
NO, NOT REALLY.
THIS IS JUST, LIKE, FUN.
IT'S NOT LIKE--
IT DOESN'T MEAN ANYTHING TO ME.
I DON'T THINK THAT
THE SARAH THING'S A BIG DEAL.
I JUST HOPE THAT SHE DOESN'T
GET THE WRONG IDEA.
DO YOU KNOW HOW IT IS
FOR HER, THOUGH?
NO.
COME FORWARD A LITTLE BIT.
THERE YOU GO. PERFECT.
THINK PRETTY
BUT STILL SCARED.
ALMOST LIKE YOU CAN'T BELIEVE
THIS IS HAPPENING TO YOU.
'CAUSE RIGHT NOW
IT'S A LITTLE TOO...
AH! OOH! AAH!
LOOK BACK BEHIND YOU AND THEN
LOOK OVER IN FRONT OF YOU.
REALLY EXPRESSIVE.
REACH FOR IT, REACH FOR IT.
GO, GO.
CORYN'S STOIC NATURE HELPED
HER WITH TODAY'S SHOOT
BECAUSE SHE DIDN'T OVERACT.
- IT'S GOOD.
- THANK YOU.
GOOD JOB.
RELAX A LITTLE BIT.
RELAX. LET IT RELAX.
YOU CAN HOLD THE PURSE
IN A DIFFERENT WAY IF YOU LIKE.
MAKE IT FEEL NATURAL.
- THAT'S NOT NATURAL, GIRL.
- NO?
PRETEND LIKE YOU'RE CASSANDRA
WITH A NEW HAIRCUT.
YOU'RE RUNNING FROM
THE SCISSORS.
SARAH LOOKED
REALLY UNCOMFORTABLE.
SHE WAS TRYING SO HARD
TO POSE IN FRONT OF THE CAMERA,
THAT I DON'T EVEN KNOW IF
WE GOT A GREAT SHOT.
LOOK A LITTLE MORE OVER HERE.
OVER HERE.
KEEP DOING THAT, THOUGH,
BUT THIS WAY.
BRE REALLY SURPRISED ME TODAY.
I HONESTLY THOUGHT
BRE WAS GONNA FALL FLAT.
SHE REALLY PULLED IT TOGETHER
TODAY.
MY WEAVE IS SWEATING.
I GOTTA GO.
ALL RIGHT.
DON'T TRY AND THINK
WHAT I LOOK LIKE,
JUST BE IT...
MAKE SENSE?
I BETTER ROCK
THIS PHOTO SHOOT OR ELSE
THAT IS GONNA BE
THE END OF ME.
STOP ANALYZING.
JUST GET INTO IT.
SOMEONE'S COMING BEHIND YOU,
LIKE, AAH!
KIM JUST JOGGED ON THE PLATFORM,
AND THAT'S ABOUT IT.
WHEN SHE'S SITTING AROUND
WITH THE GIRLS
AND GOOFING AND LAUGHING,
SHE HAS SUCH LIFE.
KIM NEVER BRINGS THAT TO SET.
THE PLACE YOU WANT TO GET TO
IS TO KIND OF PULL FROM
- THIS, LIKE, CATALOG OF POSES.
- RIGHT.
YOU CAN DO ALL SORTS
OF STUFF.
THIS WHOLE COMPETITION'S
BEEN TOUGHER THAN I EVER
THOUGHT IT WOULD BE.
THERE'S A LOT MORE THAT GOES
INTO BEING A MODEL
THAN I REALIZED.
JUST GIVE ME
SOMETHING DRAMATIC.
OVERDO IT.
KEEP OVERDOING IT.
THAT'S GOOD.
ALL RIGHT, LOOK OVER
THIS WAY A LITTLE MORE.
EXCELLENT.
I THINK NICOLE IS AFRAID OF
BEING THE MODEL SHE WANTS TO BE.
BECAUSE IN CASTING,
SHE GOT DOWN ON HER KNEES
AND BEGGED TO BE IN
THIS COMPETITION.
- WANT TO TAKE A LOOK?
- SHOULD WE?
CUTE!
THAT'S A GOOD HAIRCUT.
MY HAIR IS SHORT AGAIN,
AND IT'S EASY TO DEAL WITH.
EVERYONE LOVES IT,
AND I LOVE IT, TOO.
YOU'RE RUNNING
FOR YOUR LIFE.
IT'S ON THE BACK OF YOU.
BEAUTIFUL.
THESE ARE GOOD, JAYLA.
KEEP IT GOING.
- GOOD, RIGHT THERE.
- SHE WORKED IT.
THE NEW SHORT HAIRCUT
LOOKS AMAZING ON JAYLA.
EXCELLENT!
GO AHEAD, KYLE.
YOU'RE HOLDING ON
TO YOUR JEWELRY,
LIKE, "NO, DON'T STEAL
MY NECKLACE!"
PROTECT YOUR JEWELS.
AGAIN, DO IT AGAIN.
KYLE JUST KIND OF JOGGED
AND GRABBED HER HAIR,
AND THAT'S NOT BELIEVING IT
IN THE SCENE.
I'M NOT GONNA SCREW YOU OVER.
YOU KNOW I HAVE YOUR BACK,
ALWAYS.
YEAH.
I'M JUST GONNA ROUND OUT
THE FRONT A LITTLE BIT
SO YOU CAN GO ON
A LITTLE BIT.
IT WASN'T JUST CUTTING AN
INCH AND HALF OF HAIR FOR ME.
IT WAS THE LAST STRAW IN THEM
COMPLETELY TRYING TO CHANGE
WHO I WAS.
ROB'S READY TO CUT YOUR HAIR?
BECAUSE WE'RE GONNA START.
I'M NOT GONNA CUT IT, JAY.
YOU'RE NOT?
NO.
I'M NOT READY.
I TOLD HIM I WASN'T GONNA
CUT MY HAIR ANYMORE,
THAT I DIDN'T
THINK I NEEDED TO
IN ORDER TO BE SUCCESSFUL
AT THIS.
SO YOU'RE NOT READY
TO CUT YOUR HAIR?
NO.
YOU KNOW, I REALLY DON'T
HAVE TIME FOR THIS TODAY.
SO YOU JUST GOTTA
LEAVE MY SET.
OKAY?
CASSANDRA DID NOT WANT TO CUT
AN EXTRA INCH OFF OF HER HAIR.
I SAID TO HER, "DO YOU REALIZE,
BY NOT COMPLYING
WITH THIS HAIRCUT--
WHERE DOES THAT PUT YOU?"
AND SHE SAID, "WELL, I GUESS
I'M GONNA GO HOME."
I HAVE TO BE MYSELF,
AND I WANT TO WALK OUT OF
THIS COMPETITION KNOWING THAT
I DID WHAT I THINK WAS RIGHT
IN THE LONG RUN,
AND THAT INCLUDES NOT LETTING
PEOPLE TRY AND CHANGE
THE WAY I AM.
(cell phone rings)
Hello.
TYRA.
Yeah?
IT'S JAY.
I'M GOING HOME.
I'M GONNA GO BACK TO TEXAS
AND I'M GONNA GET
SOME HAIR EXTENSIONS,
AND HOPEFULLY YOU WILL SEE ME
AS A FUTURE MISS U.S.A.
I FEEL SO BAD FOR THAT GIRL.
I'M JUST GONNA
PUT MY HEAD DOWN.
CASSANDRA CAME INTO
THIS COMPETITION KNOWING
THAT THERE'S A GREAT CHANCE
THAT THEY WERE GONNA
CUT HER HAIR.
SHE HAD A CHOICE.
CASSANDRA CHOSE TO SAY NO.
IT'S NO TURNING BACK NOW.
SHE EVEN TOLD ME, SHE'S LIKE,
"I BET YOU THEY'RE GONNA CUT
ALL MY HAIR OFF,
ALL OF IT."
AND THEN I WAS LIKE,
"WHAT WOULD YOU DO?"
DO YOU KNOW?
AND SHE WENT LIKE THIS...
"I'LL DEAL WITH IT."
NOW THAT CASSANDRA'S GONE,
THIS IS A REAL COMPETITION
BECAUSE NOW WE HAVE SOMEONE
WHO DIDN'T REALLY WANT THIS OUT.
TYRA MAIL.
TYRA MAIL!
"TOMORROW, YOU WILL MEET
WITH THE JUDGES.
"ONLY NINE WILL CONTINUE ON
WITH THE HOPE OF BECOMING
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
ONE OF YOU
WILL BE ELIMINATED."
THE ANXIETY LEVEL
NOW THAT CASSANDRA'S GONE
AND THEY'RE STILL GONNA DO
ELIMINATIONS TOMORROW IS...
IT'S PRETTY HIGH.
MY WALK IS THE WORST HERE.
LIKE, THEY HAVE NO REASON
TO KEEP ME.
IT'S LIKE A JOKE AT THIS POINT.
I FEEL, LIKE, VERY CONCERNED
THAT I'M GOING HOME.
A WALK IS SOMETHING YOU CAN
WORK ON.
OH, DEAR.
I REALLY THINK IF I HAD,
LIKE, ONE OR TWO MORE WEEKS,
I COULD DEFINITELY, YOU KNOW,
IMPROVE AND EXCEL AT THIS.
BUT I NEED THOSE WEEKS.
I'VE PROBABLY FELT
LIKE CASSANDRA BEFORE,
WHERE IT'S LIKE,
THIS IS TOO MUCH.
I DON'T WANT THIS.
YOU KNOW?
I HAVE MY MOMENTS WHERE,
YOU KNOW,
THE STRESS GETS TO ME.
BUT IN THE END, I WANT IT.
I HONESTLY DON'T KNOW
WHO IS GOING HOME
IN ELIMINATION.
I HOPE IT'S NOT ME AND KIM.
A LOT OF THE TIMES,
GIRLS THINK THEY DID BAD
WHEN THEY DID PHENOMENAL.
UNFORTUNATELY, NOW IT'S TIME
TO MAKE OUR THIRD CUT,
WHICH WILL BRING
US ONE STEP CLOSER TOWARDS
DETERMINING WHO WILL BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
WE'VE GOT THOSE PRIZES
THAT ARE AMAZING
THAT YOU GUYS KNOW ABOUT,
BUT I'M GON' TELL YOU AGAIN.
A CONTRACT WITH TOP
MODEL MANAGEMENT COMPANY
FORD MODELS, A SPREAD
IN "ELLE" MAGAZINE SHOT BY
WORLD-RENOWNED PHOTOGRAPHER
GILLES BENSIMON,
AND ALSO A COVER
OF "ELLEgirl" MAGAZINE
AND A $100,000 CONTRACT
WITH COVER GIRL COSMETICS.
AND, OF COURSE,
YOU KNOW THESE JUDGES--
THE FIRST IS THE SEXY AND NOTED
FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER...
HI, GIRLS.
NIGEL BARKER.
MISS J. ALEXANDER,
OUR FABULOUS RUNWAY COACH.
WHAT'S UP, GIRLS?
LEGENDARY ICON IN
THE WORLD OF FASHION--TWIGGY.
AND, OF COURSE, MISS SUE WONG,
TOP FASHION DESIGNER.
HI, LADIES. HOW ARE YOU?
(all)
GOOD.
BEFORE WE GET STARTED,
I WANT TO TALK TO YOU ABOUT
CASSANDRA AND HER DECISION
TO NOT CUT HER HAIR,
WHICH WAS ALSO A DECISION
TO LEAVE THIS COMPETITION.
BEING A MODEL MEANS BEING ABLE
TO ADAPT TO A WHOLE VARIETY
OF SITUATIONS.
CASSANDRA WAS MORE INTERESTED
IN HOLDING ON TO ONE INCH
OF HAIR
THAN IN LEARNING AND ADAPTING.
SO I'M SAYING TO EACH
AND EVERY ONE OF YOU,
THINK LONG AND THINK HARD
WHY YOU'RE HERE.
AND EITHER COMMIT TO WANTING
TO BE A TOP MODEL
OR STEP FORWARD RIGHT NOW,
AND YOU CAN GO BACK TO
THE HOUSE AND PACK YOUR BAGS.
DOES ANYONE WANT TO GO HOME?
I SEE YOU THINKING
OVER THERE, LISA.
OH, NO.
I'M NOT GOIN' NOWHERE.
WELL, THEN,
WE CAN PROCEED WITH JUDGING.
NOW I'M VERY EXCITED ABOUT
THIS JUDGING TEST TODAY.
HOW MANY OF YOU ARE FAMILIAR
WITH CAMILLE FROM CYCLE TWO?
ALL RIGHTY.
AND MISS CAMILLE SAID WHAT?
"THIS IS MY SIGNATURE WALK
AND THIS IS THE WALK
THAT'S GONNA MAKE ME."
"FAMOUS."
THIS IS MY SIGNATURE WALK,
AND THIS IS WHAT'S GOING
TO MAKE ME FAMOUS.
HOLLA. EXACTLY.
SO YOU KNOW WHAT WE'RE
GONNA BE TESTING YOU ON TODAY?
YOUR SIGNATURE WALK.
WE WANT YOU TO COME UP WITH
A WALK THAT IS YOU.
ALL RIGHTY,
WE'RE GONNA GO ONE AT A TIME.
JAYLA, YOU'RE FIRST.
EVERYBODY HAS TO LEAVE.
♪♪♪
WORK IT OUT.
COME ON.
I JUST WANT TO SAY
BEFORE I WALK THAT I KNOW
I DIDN'T MAKE YOU PROUD
THE OTHER DAY.
BUT I WANT TO SHOW YOU THAT
I'M GONNA KEEP IMPROVING
AND I'M GONNA KEEP PRACTICING,
AND IT'S GONNA GET BETTER.
OKAY, I HOPE SO 'CAUSE YOU
WERE ON MY LIST, GIRL, TO BE...
WHAT WAS UP WITH
THE DISCLAIMER?
"EXCUSE ME,
I'M ABOUT TO DO REALLY BADLY.
DON'T JUDGE ME."
NOW IT'S TIME TO EVALUATE
YOUR WALK AND YOUR PHOTO.
COME ON, JAYLA.
FIRST, JAYLA,
I WANT TO COMMEND YOU ON BEING
A TROOPER
AND GETTING YOUR HAIR CUT.
THANK YOU.
- IT LOOKS FANTASTIC.
- THANKS.
ENOUGH ABOUT THE HAIR,
TIME FOR THE WALK. TWIGGY.
WHEN YOU CAME OUT, YOU LOOKED
LIKE YOU WERE JUST COMING OUT
TO GO SHOPPING OR SOMETHING.
I THINK YOU'RE IMPROVED
FROM THE FASHION SHOW,
BUT I THINK YOU DO NEED
MORE PERSONAL PRESENCE.
ALL RIGHT, JAYLA,
SO YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT
WHERE YOU WERE RUNNING ON
A TREADMILL.
YOU GUYS DIDN'T KNOW WHAT
YOU WERE RUNNING AWAY FROM,
BUT YOU WERE ACTUALLY
RUNNING AWAY
FROM THE FASHION POLICE WITCH,
AND HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
JAYLA, I THINK
THIS SHOT OF YOU LOOKS GREAT.
IT'S NOT EASY TO PULL OFF
A RUNNING SHOT.
OH, YEAH, YOU'RE SCARED
BUT STILL PRETTY,
- AND THAT'S HARD TO DO.
- WELL DONE.
AND CAN WE TELL WHO
THE FASHION POLICE WITCH IS?
- GOODNESS.
- THAT IS MISS J. HIMSELF.
ALL RIGHTY, NEXT IS CORYN.
SUE, DO YOU WANT TO COMMENT
ON CORYN'S WALK?
WELL, I THOUGHT IT WAS
A LITTLE BIT TOO STOIC,
A LITTLE BIT
TOO STIFF.
BUT WHAT IT ISN'T
IS A SIGNATURE WALK.
AND YOUR SIGNATURE IS
THIS POUT THAT YOU HAVE,
AND I THINK YOU NEED
A SIGNATURE SMILE.
YOU JUST--LOOK AT THIS.
- LOOK, LOOK.
- BEAUTIFUL.
ALL RIGHT, CORYN,
SO YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT,
AND HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
WELL, IT'S CERTAINLY A LOOK.
SHE HAS ON
THE OLD VELOUR TRACK SUITS.
- YOU KNOW,
THE J .LO TRACK SUITS?
RIGHT, RIGHT.
THAT EVERYBODY'S SAYING
ARE SO OUT.
I LIKE THE CLOSE-UP BETTER
THAN THE LONG SHOT.
YOU DIDN'T REALLY LOOK LIKE
YOU WERE MOVING.
BECAUSE YOU HAD ON
A TRACK SUIT,
- YOU SHOULDA RAN FOR REAL.
- YEAH.
ALL RIGHTY,
UP NEXT WE HAVE DIANE.
DIANE, YOU WALKED
AT AN ANGLE.
BUT YOU GOTTA REMEMBER THERE'S
ANOTHER GIRL COMING BACK AT YOU
SOMETIMES, AND SHE'S GONNA BE
THROWN BY THAT.
YOU SHOULD WALK AS IF THERE'S
WIND BLOWING IN YOUR HAIR.
YOU HAVE TO CREATE
YOUR OWN WIND.
ALL RIGHT, DIANE,
HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
YOU LOOK COMPLETELY STATIC.
WERE YOU ON A RUNNING MACHINE?
I WAS RUNNING SO HARD,
I WAS SWEATING AFTERWARDS.
I WAS LIKE,
"GET ME OUT OF HERE."
CAN WE SEE A CLOSE-UP OF
THE FASHION WITCH?
MISS J.
(laughs)
YOU LOOK LIKE THE PURPLE
PEOPLE EATER.
J., I'VE SEEN THIS LOOK
BEFORE IN ANOTHER PICTURE.
YOU'VE GOTTA VARY YOUR LOOK.
OKAY, UP NEXT IS KIM.
KIM, WHAT WAS UP
WITH THAT DISCLAIMER?
WHY DID YOU FEEL THE NEED TO
EXPLAIN YOURSELF
BEFORE YOU WALKED?
I KNOW THAT MY WALK HAS BEEN
PROBABLY MY BIGGEST OBSTACLE.
I'M JUST NOT THERE YET.
BUT I THINK
YOU MISSED THE MARK, KIM.
YOU LEARNED HOW TO DO
ALL THAT FEMININE STUFF,
BUT TODAY I ASKED FOR
A SIGNATURE WALK.
KIM, I ASKED FOR YOU TODAY.
I'M CONSTANTLY TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT WHAT MY GENDER IS.
THAT'S HARD IN LIFE,
IN THIS COMPETITION, EVERY DAY,
ALL THE TIME.
I SUGGEST THAT YOU GET SOME
MALE FASHION MAGAZINES.
BECAUSE WHEN MEN MODEL,
THEY'RE SLIGHTLY FEMININE.
RIGHT.
YOU COULD LEARN
FROM LOOKING AT THAT
AS WELL AS FEMALE MAGAZINES.
SO YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT,
AND HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
WOW, KIM, THAT DOESN'T LOOK
ANYTHING LIKE YOU.
EXTRAORDINARY. VERY FEMININE.
GREAT SHOT.
STRAIGHT ON FACE, AND IT
LOOKS AMAZING.
ALL RIGHTY,
UP NEXT WE HAVE KYLE.
FOR ME,
YOU HAD THE BEST WALK.
I THOUGHT YOU LOOKED
ABSOLUTELY BEAUTIFUL.
YOU'VE GOT
AN AMAZING PAIR OF LEGS.
THE WIND WAS IN YOUR HAIR.
IT WAS BLOWING LIKE
THERE WAS A BIG OLD FAN
GOING...
(makes whirring noise)
ALL RIGHT, KYLE,
HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
YOU HAVE TO LEARN YOUR ANGLES
A LITTLE BIT BETTER.
THAT FACE TWISTED AROUND
THAT MUCH GIVES
A BIG SWATHE OF SKIN.
SO YOU YOU HAVE TO REALIZE
WHERE THE PHOTOGRAPHER IS
AND JUST CHEAT IT.
OKAY, THANK YOU.
UP NEXT, WE HAVE LISA.
YEAH.
I THOUGHT YOUR WALK WAS GOOD,
AND I THOUGHT IT WAS SAFE.
THAT'S A GOOD THING TO HAVE
AS A BASE, NOW MAKE IT HOT,
NOW MAKE IT SEXY,
NOW MAKE IT STRONGER, NOW PUSH.
- OKAY.
- HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
YOU LOST YOUR NECK.
YOU SEE THAT, LISA?
NO NECK.
- THAT WAS A TURTLE NECK, TOO.
- DOESN'T MATTER.
IT HAS NOTHING TO DO
WITH THE TURTLENECK.
IF YOU DIDN'T HAVE A TURTLE
NECK ON,
YOU WOULD STILL
HAVE NO NECK.
UP NEXT IS NICOLE.
NICOLE, COME ON.
YOU SHOULD HAVE PUT YOUR HAND
ON THE TOP OF YOUR SKIRT
AND KIND OF HELD IT
AND MADE IT PART OF YOUR WALK.
CAN I START OFF
BY APOLOGIZING FOR THAT?
YOU NEVER SHOW YOUR OOPS.
OKAY.
HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
IT'S A WEAK PICTURE,
PERSONALLY.
MR. J. SAID THAT
HE FELT THAT YOU WERE BLAND
AND THAT THE CAMERA LOVES YOU,
BUT THAT YOU DON'T
LOVE THE CAMERA.
I DON'T KNOW.
I THINK I LOVE THE CAMERA.
NIK.
ALL RIGHT, NIK, SO YOU HAD
TO SERVE YOUR SIGNATURE WALK.
I GOTTA SAY, THE NECK THING--
IT'S LIKE,
"I'M CHILLIN' AND I'M STROLLING
DOWN THE STREET,
BOPPIN' TO THE BEAT."
- I CALLED YOU THE BOBBLEHEAD.
- AND AGAIN, WIND IN THE HAIR.
YOU'RE A PERFECT CANDIDATE
FOR WIND IN THE HAIR
'CAUSE YOU HAVE SO MUCH.
AND HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
FACIALLY, NIK,
THIS LOOKS FANTASTIC.
YOUR FACE LOOKS BEAUTIFUL,
I WOULD HAVE LIKED
A LITTLE BIT MORE INTENSITY.
'CAUSE RIGHT NOW, YOU'RE LIKE,
"I'M PRETTY, I'M RUNNING."
INSTEAD OF... HA!
YOU KNOW? HA!
OKAY.
UP NEXT--BRE.
MISS BRE, I GOTTA SAY, I LOVED
YOUR SIGNATURE WALK.
ALMOST PERFECT.
I HAVE A BIT OF TROUBLE
WITH THOSE HORSE LEGS.
IT WAS TOO HORSY FOR ME.
WELL, I LOVED IT.
I THOUGHT
IT WAS A GREAT DIVA WALK.
I WOULD HIRE YOU.
BRE, YOU ARE ON A TREADMILL?
MM-HMM.
WOW. IT LOOKS LIKE
YOU WERE STANDING STILL.
THAT'S WHAT I THOUGHT, TOO,
AT THE BUS STOP.
"HEY, GIRL. I'M COMING.
YOU TALKIN' TO ME?"
YOU WORKED THAT WALK, THOUGH,
AND SHE WAS THE WINNER
OF THE WALKING CHALLENGE
THIS WEEK.
UP NEXT IS SARAH.
IT LOOKED LIKE YOU
WERE GOING CROOKED.
A LITTLE TO THE LEFT.
AND ONE LEG
MOVED VERY STRANGE.
LIKE "MY LEFT FOOT."
YOU'VE DEFINITELY IMPROVED
FROM TRIPPING
AND ALL THAT KIND OF THING.
I THOUGHT PERHAPS YOU WERE
GONNA FALL DOWN THE STAIRS.
ME, TOO.
I WAS WAITING FOR YOU
TO FALL DOWN THE STAIRS.
YOU JUST LOOK PECULIAR.
IT LOOKS REALLY UNCOMFORTABLE.
IT LOOKS LIKE
YOU'RE IN PAIN.
I THINK POISE IS
THE OPERATIVE WORD HERE.
THAT'S REALLY
WHAT YOU NEED TO WORK ON.
SO NOW IT'S TIME FOR
THE JUDGES TO DELIBERATE.
AND WHEN WE CALL YOU BACK,
I WILL ANNOUNCE WHICH ONE OF YOU
WILL BE ELIMINATED.
CORYN.
SHE'S VERY TIMID, VERY SAD,
AND IT DOES COME ACROSS
ON THE PICTURES.
BRE.
NOW BRE HAPPENS TO BE
ONE OF MY FAVORITES.
SHE'S GOT THAT DIVA ATTITUDE.
I LOVE
THE PERSONALITY OF BRE,
BUT I'M NOT GETTING IT
IN THE PICTURES.
- KYLE.
- I LOVE HER BODY,
BUT THERE IS NO WOW FACTOR
WITH HER.
TODAY I SAW SOMETHING
THAT I HADN'T SEEN BEFORE.
SO, FOR ME, SHE'S STILL IN.
SARAH.
SARAH IS A MESS.
BUT IF YOU LOOK AT WHERE
SHE STARTED WITH THAT
RUNWAY WALK
AND WHERE SHE IS NOW,
I THINK
SHE'S REALLY PROGRESSED.
SHE LOOKS LIKE SHE'S ABOUT
TO GET HIT BY A TAXI.
LISA.
I FIND HER TO BE
A LITTLE CONTRIVED.
I THINK SHE'S REALLY BEAUTIFUL
TO LOOK AT, BUT IT'S SOMETHING
ABOUT HER THAT'S
A POINT MISSING, AND I CAN'T
PUT MY FINGER ON THE POINT.
- NICOLE.
- I THINK SHE'S VERY SEXY.
SHE'S GOT THAT PERIOD,
OLD PAINTING THING.
SHE'S A LITTLE BLAND
ON THE PERSONALITY.
THIS PHOTOGRAPH
IS AVERAGE AT BEST.
JAYLA.
JAYLA'S HAIRCUT
SAVED THE DAY.
- AND I LOVE THAT PICTURE.
- YES.
THAT'S ONE OF THE ONES
THAT REALLY WORKS FOR ME.
SHE HAD QUITE A SET OF...
- SHE'S GOT A LOT OF EARS.
- NOTHING WRONG WITH BIG EARS.
- I'VE GOT BIG EARS.
- LET ME SEE YOUR BIG EARS.
- LET ME SEE, DARLING.
- THEY'RE HUGE.
DIANE.
DIANE IS ABSOLUTELY HOPELESS
IN PERSON.
SHE'S LIKE
ALL OVER THE PLACE.
AND I THINK LITTLE DIANE
IS VERY, VERY SEXY,
- AND I SAY SHE'S IN.
- KIM.
I LOVE KIM.
I LOVE HER UNUSUALNESS.
ANDROGYNY REALLY
MAKES HER KIND OF INTERESTING.
ALTHOUGH SHE THREW ME
A BIT TODAY WITH THAT SPEECH.
I WISH
SHE HADN'T HAVE DONE THAT.
AND TO ME, SHE WALKED AS THOUGH
SHE HAD AN OVERDOSE OF VIAGRA.
NIK.
SHE LOOKS LIKE THE GIRL
FROM BUILDING "C"
IN THE PROJECTS.
THERE WAS ALWAYS THAT
REALLY PRETTY LIGHT-SKINNED
LITTLE GIRL WITH GOOD HAIR.
- IN THE PROJECTS?
- IN THE PROJECTS.
I NEED TO GO TO THE PROJECTS
MORE OFTEN.
TEN BEAUTIFUL GIRLS STAND
BEFORE ME,
BUT I ONLY HAVE
NINE PHOTOS IN MY HANDS.
AND THESE NINE PHOTOS
REPRESENT THE YOUNG LADIES
THAT WILL STILL BE
IN THE RUNNING TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE FIRST NAME THAT I'M GOING
TO CALL...
JAYLA.
CONGRATULATIONS FOR BEING
CALLED FIRST.
- THANK YOU.
- YOU KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS?
YOU DID A DAMN GOOD JOB
THIS WEEK.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE NEXT NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL...
KYLE.
THE JUDGES WEREN'T VERY EXCITED
ABOUT YOU THE LAST COUPLE
OF WEEKS,
BUT THAT RUNWAY WALK TODAY,
MISS THING,
CHANGED THEIR MINDS.
CONGRATULATIONS.
NIK.
BRE.
BRE, THREE WEEKS IN A ROW,
THREE PICTURES THAT AREN'T
THAT GREAT.
BUT THE REASON WHY
I CALLED YOUR NAME IS BECAUSE
YOUR WALK IS SO FIERCE,
I HAD TO GIVE YOU A SNAP.
THANK YOU.
CONGRATULATIONS.
LISA.
DIANE.
CORYN.
NICOLE.
YOU SAY THAT YOU LOVE
THE CAMERA,
BUT SHOW US THAT YOU LOVE IT.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
- THANK YOU.
- YOU'RE WELCOME.
WILL SARAH AND KIM
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
I ONLY HAVE ONE PHOTO
IN MY HANDS,
AND I WILL ONLY CALL ONE NAME.
THE GIRL THAT I DO NOT CALL
MUST IMMEDIATELY RETURN TO
THE HOUSE THAT YOU WERE
STAYING IN, PACK YOUR BELONGINGS
AND GO HOME.
ONE OF YOU WANTS THIS SO MUCH,
HAS GONE THROUGH LEAPS
AND BOUNDS
AND THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
TO BE A MODEL,
BUT SHE GETS CONFUSED
AND DISCOMBOBULATED,
AND SOMETIMES WE WANT SOMETHING
SO MUCH, THAT WHEN WE'RE ASKED
TO GO AND PERFORM,
WE FALL APART.
AND THE OTHER PERSON
REALLY WANTS IT BAD AND SAYS
THAT THEY'RE CONFUSED,
THAT THEY'RE ON THE QUEST
TO FINDING OUT WHO THEY ARE
AND FEELS THE NEED
TO MAKE A DISCLAIMER
ABOUT HER PERFORMANCE.
AND ALL A DISCLAIMER DOES
IS POINT TO THE NEGATIVE THINGS,
THINGS THAT SOMEBODY
JUDGING YOU WOULD HAVE
NEVER SEEN.
SO DON'T DO IT AGAIN, KIM.
THANK YOU.
JUST MAKE THE MISTAKES,
AND HOPEFULLY WE WON'T SEE
ALL OF THE ONES
THAT YOU THINK THAT WE WILL.
- ALL RIGHT.
- CONGRATULATIONS.
THANK YOU.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THANK YOU.
THANKS, SARAH.
I'M GLAD I CAME AND EVEN
THOUGH I DIDN'T WIN,
I LEARNED
THINGS ABOUT MYSELF.
SO IT WAS WORTH IT.
KIM TAUGHT ME A LOT ABOUT
MYSELF.
I LEARNED THAT I'M STRONGER THAN
I THOUGHT I WAS.
AND I DON'T KNOW,
I WISH I COULD LEARN MORE.
BACK TO BOONVILLE, I GUESS.
AND, UH, WE'LL SEE FROM THERE.
COMING UP ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"...
THE GIRLS LET THEIR HAIR DOWN,
AND THEN SOME...
- LET'S TAKE SOME TOPLESS ONES.
- YEAH.
BE SEXY.
I WANT SEXY.
AND WHEN LISA TRIES TO LEND
A HELPING HAND...
YOU NEED TO STOP WORKING OUT.
SHE GETS BURNED.
I JUST DO NOT LIKE YOU.
IT'S JUST GONNA MAKE YOU
FEEL BAD.
I FEEL A LOT BETTER.
♪♪♪